ما الذي يحدث هناك، لا أبدو هكذا، هل
أبدو كذلك، لقد
شهدنا هذا العام انفجارًا في
منتجات مختلفة للذكاء الاصطناعي، مثل Chachi
BT للنص، وقد رأينا محاكيات صوتية تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي في
عدد قليل من الشركات على الرغم من أنها
تبيع صورًا للرأس تعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي  الفكرة هي أن
تلتقط بعض الصور على هاتفك وترفعها
إلى السحابة ثم باستخدام سحر الذكاء الاصطناعي
تحصل على مجموعة كاملة من
الصور المختلفة التي تم إنشاؤها بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي، إنها مضحكة،
سنلقي نظرة ونرى ما إذا كان
بإمكاننا تحديث ملفي الشخصي على LinkedIn  باستخدام
إحدى هذه الصور ومقارنتها بالصور
التي التقطها منتجي، دعنا نجربها
جيدًا، لذا فهم يقدمون ثلاثة
أسعار مختلفة، هناك إصدار 29 إصدار 39 إصدار
69، سنستخدم
الإصدار 39 وستحصل على 120 صورة في
ثلاث صور مختلفة  أنماط رقم بطاقة الائتمان
قيد الانتظار إذا قلنا ذلك على
الكاميرا أو هناك عدد قليل من
الخيارات المختلفة الآن يمكنك تحديدها في الهواء الطلق أو
في الداخل يمكنك تحديد مكان
التقاط الصور بحيث يكون هناك حديقة أو غابة
وبعد ذلك يمكنك اختيار
الملابس التي نريدها  سنذهب مع لاعب
بولو لطيف وأنيق ومحترف وليس
محترفًا للغاية، لذا فقد ورد في الموقع أنه
يوصي باستخدام
كاميرا احترافية للعناية بالصور التي ستقوم
بتحميلها، وهو أمر مثير للسخرية بعض الشيء
لأنه إذا كان لديك
كاميرا احترافية  يمكنك فقط التقاط
صور احترافية لنفسك، ونحن في الواقع
سنفعل ذلك باستخدام هاتف iPhone
وسنرى ما إذا كانت اختيارات الصور الشخصية على iPhone يمكنها القيام
بالخدعة حسنًا، فلنحمل هذه
الصور
[موسيقى]
علينا فقط أن نلاحظ أن الصور
جاهزون، لم أرهم بعد، هذه هي
الصور التي تم إنشاؤها بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي والتي
تشبهني ولكن ميجا جاك
ليس لدي هذا الصدر، وهذه
القلادة التي أعطتني
قلادة صغيرة حسنًا، لذلك نحن ننظر إليهم كما
تعلم  في الشبكة اليمنى مما يعني
أنها ليست مغلقة ويبدو ذلك
مثاليًا بهذا الحجم عندما أنقر عليها،
يمكنك أن تبدأ في رؤية أن هناك
نوعًا من الأشياء المضحكة التي تم إنشاؤها بواسطة الكمبيوتر
تحدث كما لو أنها سلسة جدًا ولا
تفعل ذلك  لا أشعر أنني بخير تمامًا،
حسنًا، لقد وجدنا أول صورة غريبة لنا، أنا
AI Avatar كانت تقضي ليلة صعبة
عندما تم التقاط هذه الصورة في أرض الذكاء الاصطناعي